this is a production of cornell
university
okay fantastic so thank you very much
larry for those kind words uh today i'm
going to be talking about the research
that i've been doing for my thesis
titled elucidating the genetic control
of qualitative traits in hemp
so before i get into the research i'd
like to give a little bit of a
background of what hemp is so hemp
is cannabis sativa a species that it
shares with the uh currently federally
illegal plant marijuana but the
difference between hemp and marijuana is
the concentration of one chemical and
that is thc which is psychoactive
notably hemp has less than 0.3 thc while
marijuana has greater than 0.3 thc and
this is a very important number and i'll
get back to it later on in the
presentation
hemp is usually dioecious diploid and
short day but there are some exceptions
to this and i'll talk about those later
as well and what's really interesting
about hemp is that it's really a
multi-purpose crop there are a few major
market classes that hemp can be grown
for the three most important of which
are grain
fiber and inflorescence
so at the moment right now the smallest
market both in terms of acreage and in
terms of economic impact and at least in
the united states is hemp for grain uh
that being said i think that there's
great opportunities for hemp as a grain
crop and for the people who are here
please help yourself to the snacks in
the back which i largely made using hemp
hearts as pictured here uh so these hemp
hearts which are the uh the seed once
you remove the the hard shell on the
outside uh they've got a bit of a
reputation as a superfood they're
relatively high in uh oil with a three
to one omega-6 to omega-3 fatty acid
profile which is largely accepted to be
optimal for human health they're high in
highly digestible protein and uh today
you can buy this grain hemp in many
places uh either whole with that shell
on dehulled as you can see in the back
with these hearts this picture up here
uh you can also either extract the oil
from the whole seeds or the dehulled
seeds and the remaining protein-rich
cake can be further processed to create
protein isolates
so the next largest major market class
of hemp is for fiber and the part of the
plant that you grow hemp for for fiber
is the stem uh so what happens if you
cut that stem right across you would see
two distinct parts of the stem you'd see
the outer bass fibers which are strong
durable and can be treated to make some
very nice textiles like this tie that
i'm wearing right here uh the inside is
a woody herd and it can basically be
used for anything that you could use
wood for so it's very commonly pulped
or
chopped into small pieces for animal
bedding
so what's great about the hemp is that
it can be grown all over it's widely
adapted to very different regions and
you can get potentially very high yields
this is a field that we grew last year
and some of these plants were 16 feet
tall
and we were getting upwards of 20
megagrams per hectare of dry reddit
fiber from these plants uh in fact uh
the biomass of these plants is so
prodigious uh
it's at least comparable to the uh the
best willow lines that we have been uh
testing as the other part of larry's
program
so the last major market class for hemp
which is by far and away the most
profitable right now but it has been
shrinking greatly since 2019
is inflorescence hemp
so inflorescent samp is usually grown
for the cannabinoids and the terpenes
which reached their highest
concentration in unpollinated female
inflorescences
so while the other two major market
classes grain and fiber are mostly grown
as a row crop the inflorescence hemp is
much more horticultural we'll grow them
on a plant-by-plant basis will go
through
extraordinary lengths to make sure that
there's no pollination and no males in
the field and um
we'll yeah we'll put a lot more effort
into growing these plants uh so it's a
very interesting market in that right
now there seems to be a uh a split in
what people grow in fluorescence hemp
for um on the one hand there's the
smokable flower and then on the other
hand it is the uh the extract of this
high cbd with the terpenes
and uh these are forming very different
market classes and we're seeing it
evolve in real time
so for my thesis what i really wanted to
address were some of the major problems
that we're facing hemp so hemp is a very
new crop it was first able to be grown
in the u.s um with a research license in
the 2014 farm bill so there's a lot of
new challenges that face this crop
and uh there was an interesting study
published by shelby ellison from
university of wisconsin-madison who did
a pull of uh
stakeholders in the hemp business and
far and away the most important aspect
for hemp was that of regulatory research
so the major plant here was that the
plants that were being grown produced
too much thc so the big question was
what makes these plants produce too much
thc because we don't want to plant a
hemp field and have it actually be
marijuana
other major problems that i felt that i
could address with my thesis were a lack
of adapted cultivars and a lack of
stable cultivars and a major thing that
motivated a lot of my research was the
development of molecular markers which
could aid in developing adapted and
stable cultivars
so the big problem kept going hot so
hemp producing more than 0.3 thc so we
really want to figure out how can we
stay below that threshold so in plant
breeding we generally like to partition
things into genetic causes environmental
causes for the interaction between the
two so this is sort of a nature versus
nurture idea
and
if we look at what was commonly believed
as recently as a few years ago
the big thing that caused hemp to go hot
would be stress
so if we uh look at this here
um
these top two are hemp sites uh
which very clearly state growers need to
be aware that plant stresses can result
in thc spikes or any plant stress can
tip it over the 0.3 thc and the whole
crop is mowed down and uh even if we
look at for instance cooperative
extension sites in 2018 we have here the
main things that can cause thc spikes
are stressors and there was even
actually an article in the new york
times about a cork in the chemistry of
hemp plants that can cause them to
overproduce thc when stressed so coming
into it it seemed like everybody thought
it was the environment
so overall
we wanted to address this
started addressing this in 2018 with our
cultivar trials and i have here the cbd
and thc levels of a few different
cultivars
grain cultivars in blue
uh fiber cultivars in orange dual
purpose grain and fiber cultivars in
gray and then our cbd cultivars and teal
over there and what you can see is that
some of these grain cultivars produce
mostly cbd but a very small amount and a
much smaller amount of thc but some of
those cultivars grown under the same
conditions the same stressors they
produce way more thc well over that
threshold and you see that same genetic
difference looking at these different
cultivars grain fiber and dual purpose
and when we look at the cdd production
things get a little bit stranger uh
so with these cbd
cultivars
we measured things on a per plant basis
as opposed to a per plot basis like we
did with the other ones
and uh when we average it out by
cultivar you can see here it's just kind
of wild but one important thing to note
is that everything we tested was
considerably above that 0.3 thc
threshold
so one of the things that we did because
we had this per plant basis of
cannabinoids we plotted the cbd against
the thc
and rather remarkably we see three
distinct groups when we look at this per
plant cbd to thc ratio we have that one
group at the top that's almost entirely
thc and very close to zero cbd we have
about equal cbd and phc and then we have
that group at the bottom
which is uh
mostly cbd
uh i can just give uh
there we go
so we aren't actually the first ones to
see this phenomenon this has been
uh the subject of a lot of research from
many different groups and what has been
uh found out is that whether a plant
produces majority cbd majority thc or
about equal of both can really be
attributed to one single locus which is
called the b locus so when you get into
the the nitty-gritty molecular genetics
it's kind of a mess but from a plant
breeding perspective it doesn't really
matter all that really matters is that
we have a bd allele which has an active
cbda synthase and no active thca
synthase we have a bt allele which has
active thca synthesis and no active cbda
synthesis and because hemp is usually
diploid
you can have a heterozygous case so it
has active copies of both and this maps
on exactly what we saw we have chemotype
1 plants which are almost entirely thc
chemotype 2 which are about equal they
tend to skew a little towards cbd and
then chemotype 3 which are majority cbd
so one of the first things i did when i
started working here was develop
molecular markers which could
distinguish these loci and when i
applied that to my uh cbd trials on the
per plant basis i saw perfect
segregation into these three distinct
groups which map onto these chemotypes
that have been previously described
what's really notable though is that if
we look at these blue dots here which
are those chemotype 3 plants the ones
that don't have an active thca synthase
even
when you when you go above around seven
percent total potential cbd you get
above 0.3
thc so it doesn't appear that simply
being chemotype 3 is enough to keep you
under that total potential thc
so given my last slide i think it's
pretty clear that genetics has a very
strong role in determining if dhc goes
high so we have a theory that in the
past people were sampling a stressed
plant that happened to be chemotype one
or two and then they saw that it had
extreme amounts of thc and then they
blamed the stress
rather than the genetics
so
even given all that it's still possible
that there was an environmental effect
either on total thc or on that ratio of
cbd to thc in our previous trials we
weren't actively trying to kill the
plants so it's hard to you know really
say that we were um
stressing them out uh so we stressed
them out and tried to kill them uh we
did one site with three distinct
chemotype three cultivers in a split pot
design and we applied a few different
stresses to these plants we had a
control plot we sprayed some with
ethaphon we sprayed some with herbicide
and that's what's pictured here and that
plant was very stressed it was it was
pretty nearly dead there we also
infected some plants with powdery mildew
with the idea that maybe cannabinoids
are for pathogen resistant so they'd be
upregulated
we also went at them with a weed whacker
and we also flooded a plot as well
so remarkably nothing increased thc over
control so not only does
stress you know not it's not
just that genetics has a large effect it
appears to be the only thing that
matters here
so if we look at this total thc nothing
was above our control for total thc but
our herbicide treated plants were
considerably below that total thc and
that makes a lot of sense because those
plants were very nearly dead and as
we're fond of saying in the lab a dead
plant produces no cannabinoids but if we
look at that ratio of cbd to thc across
all cultivars across all environments
it's flat across the board um somewhere
between 20 and 30.
so there's no change in cbd to thc ratio
upon any environmental stress that we
tried
so an obvious question is why is this
ratio so consistent
and to answer this we think the answer
comes from a paper that was published in
2018 from a group in germany where they
took the cbda synthase enzyme that one
that makes the cbd
and they expressed it in yeast
and what they found was that for every
hundred molecules of cbd that this
enzyme produced it also produced about
four molecules of thc and remarkably
that's exactly what we see in the plants
so
we have strong reason to believe that
it's just this product promiscuity it's
this one enzyme that's making this thc
as well as the cbd now what's more
if this model were correct it makes an
interesting prediction in that
while this
um enzyme made a hundred molecules of
cbd and about four of thc it also made
about six of another cannabinoid called
cbc so we went back to our cannabinoid
trials and lo and behold
that's the ratio that we saw in the vast
majority of plants for cbc to cbd so we
have strong evidence that it's product
promiscuity of the single enzyme that is
causing the vast majority of these
cannabinoids in the plant because the
cbd thc to cbc ratio in most plants
matches the enzyme exactly now there are
a few
outliers in terms of cvc production some
of them have abnormally high cbc
production and other groups have found
dedicated cbc asyn phases but in most of
the plants that we've tested that's not
the case and this cannabinoid profile
can be explained by this single enzyme
so with all of this we have some very
concrete advice to growers we suggest to
them to grow chemotype 3 plants don't
grow chemotype 1 and 2 plants if you
want to stay below 0.3 because you won't
be able to and we also suggest them to
test the plants early and to not get
greedy because it looks like because
that ratio is
set
at around seven percent
it's going to produce 0.3 percent thc so
if we have to stay under 0.3 thc we have
to stay under 7
cbd
now as i mentioned earlier one of the
first things i did was create molecular
markers and um next up i'm going to talk
about how i applied these in a breeding
context
so we've tested
a lot of different cultivars and a lot
of cultivars are segregating for this
the locus
in fact i didn't mention it earlier but
in our cbd trial i had 13 cultivars and
12 of them
had
active thca synthase they had that bt
allele so we came across a couple of
interesting cultivars from china
on this one puma and this other one han
northwest
and when we
applied our molecular markers to these
uh we saw that there was uh
about a 25 of the plants were chemotype
1 about 25 or chemotype 3 and then about
half or chemotype 2. so this is exactly
what you'd expect to see for a
population in hardy-weinberg's
equilibrium with an allele frequency of
about 0.25
or sorry about 0.5 um but in any case
what we wanted to do was simply select
the chemotype 3 plants out of this and
we can do that with the molecular marker
which is a much easier thing to do than
to select based on hplc analysis
so i
uh
have made progress in both of these
projects but unfortunately due to some
varieties in the weather i don't have
much data to present on puma but i do
have some interesting data on this han
northwest population
so if we look at the
original ratio of the cbd to thc of han
northwest it's around 0.7 so it's pretty
low and when you look at that total thc
it's up pretty high well above that 0.3
threshold when i selected my plants and
then did two further cycles of
phenotypic selection based on earliness
we can see that cbd to thc ratio goes
well up above 20 and we look at the
total thc which is the number that
matters we're very low at around 0.06
so this one round of marker selection
was very effective in removing that
active thca synthase enzyme and reducing
the total thc in the plant now last year
we had our first yield trial of this
cultivar and before i get into how well
it yielded i want to talk a little bit
about how hemp generally yields uh so in
2021 it was the first year that the usda
released estimates on hemp yields and
pounds breaker and it's pretty low 530
is not that great even compared to other
specialty crops and this is largely
because of a lack of adapted cultivars a
lot of the grain cultivars were bred
in canada or in finland so they're not
going to grow all that well in new york
much less in florida or texas
so this 530
matches pretty well with our experience
uh this is 2020 yield data and we can
see that uh most of the cultivars that
we tried were around 500 to a thousand
pounds per acre
our best ever trial cultivar was a
little bit above 2000 pounds per acre
but we haven't really been able to
replicate that and the best hemp yield
i've ever seen in the literature and i
haven't really been able to track down
exactly how it was done but they're
reporting yields of up to three thousand
pounds per acre so if we could get up to
3 000 pounds per acre regularly
uh hemp could be a competitor to soybean
so we were we're really excited and you
know when i started that was the big
dream maybe we can have the next soybean
if we can get this 3 000 pounds per acre
um as a regular thing so in 2021 we
tried this new cultivar and most of the
old cultivars that we tried were again
around that 500 to a thousand range but
this new cultivar here
yielded above 4 000 and was in fact
pushing 5 000 pounds per acre
so i'm sort of tempted just to stop
there and claim that i 10xed the hemp
yield from 500 to 5000.
uh but there are a couple of big caveats
there uh so first of all even though i
did a couple of rounds of selection for
earliness um
this plant was still very very late we
were harvesting around october 15th and
in ithaca the last day of frost is
usually expected to be about october 1st
so um we don't really want to advise
growing plants that are going to mature
after frost uh the other major thing
which um
is a big asterisk on this number is that
these plants in the fields were giants
they were 10 feet tall easily and that
meant that our regular combine couldn't
harvest them so we had to harvest them
by hand and it's it's pretty well known
and not talked about much that uh when
you harvest a plant by a combine you end
up losing about 30
of the total yield so these
these ones here are regular cultivars
they're
artificially depressed in that we lost a
lot in the combining process that we
didn't lose
in this new cultivar that we developed
um so with all that being said we think
that there are answers to these problems
with advancements in machinery and uh
perhaps to deal with the the lateness
problem growing it at a more southern uh
latitude and we have um
collaborated with uh various people from
nc state from kentucky uh from florida
and from
arizona who will be trialing this
cultivar next year to see what kind of
yields they can get off of it and if the
plant will remain manageable enough that
it can be harvested using conventional
means uh so
um i think i've demonstrated that these
molecular markers have been very
effective in
developing new cultivars uh but they
also led to some interesting scientific
advances
uh so this is the chromatogram that i
get when i run my molecular marker these
are chemotype 1 plants these are
chemotype 2 plants and these are
chemotype 3 plants
and this is my uh my water control so
there there's no amplification
um and uh yeah there's no no product
present
so when i was running this on a wide
variety of different cultivars one of
the cultivars consistently tested with
my water control so there was no
amplification going there and what was
remarkable about that is that that
cultivar was santhika which is not
chemotype 1 2 or 3 but rather chemotype
4 which is cbg dominant and why that
makes a lot of sense i'll i'll discuss
but i'll have to get into the
biochemistry a little bit here
so this is how cannabinoids get
synthesized the first cannabinoid that
gets synthesized is cbga
if cbda
synthase is present the cdga gets
converted into cbd
and then um upon application of heat it
can be decarboxylated into cbd which is
the active compound when thca synthase
present it gets converted into thca and
then thc
and what you can imagine would be some
block here
that might be an inactivated cbd
synthesis or an activated thc asynthesis
or maybe it lacks those cannabinoid
synthesis genes altogether
so with a combination of sequencing
molecular marker work and looking at
breeding histories we found that there
were four distinct routes to cbg
dominance so
that santhika plant that i was showing
you earlier it didn't amplify because it
was missing that locus we also found
another one of the mixing locust called
panickea and it has a very distinct
breeding history so we don't think it's
the same knockout we found one type of
inactivated cbd asynthesis so it had
that gene and it was
expressed but expressed much lower
but it was inactivated we have an
inactivated thca synthase which is
actually highly expressed but it doesn't
seem to produce thc and we're currently
in the process of ensuring that these
are in fact completely recessive and
developing molecular markers for all of
these different routes
so
the most common type of cvg plant we saw
had this inactivated thca synthase
and uh
what we did in 2020 was a cbg trial of
pi cbg plants and
there was a lot of segregation in this
trial uh so cbg was sort of the new cam
cannabinoid on the block so everybody
was uh breeding for it very quickly and
they didn't maybe do all that great of a
job making sure that their resultant
cultivars were uniform distinct and
stable so we saw a lot of segregation in
the cbd trial we saw segregation for
chemotypes so not all the plants that
were given to us as cbg dominant were in
fact cbg dominant we saw some
segregation between and within cultivars
for powdery mildew resistance uh quite
remarkably we saw some segregation for
flowering time uh so in a few of the
cultivars we had one quarter of the
plants look like this and three quarters
of the plants look like that and you
know if i was growing that i'd sure hate
that because i put a lot of work into
putting that but as a geneticist i love
it when things happen at one quarter
time
uh so before i get on to the work that
i've been doing with flowering time i
would like to uh summarize the work i've
been doing with cannabinoids so we've
seen that many cultivars including high
cbd cultivars and grain and fiber
cultivars are segregating for chemotype
and chemotype 3 plants the ones with
that active cbd synthase will produce
0.3 thc at around seven or eight percent
cbd
and we think that that is because of
promiscuous activity of the enzyme
itself we found that contrary to popular
belief stress does not have a major
impact on cannabinoid profiles found
several different types of cbd dominant
plants and use molecular markers for
chemotype to breed new cultivars with
very high yields
so getting into flowering time firing
times is going to be very important for
pretty well any
major market class of hemp that we were
going to grow uh the great yield that i
saw was because the plant was so late um
i showed you earlier in the cbg trials
we had cultivars which were segregating
with one quarter for that game neutral
very tiny phenotype and uh that we've
been tracking flowering time in cbd
trials for a few years now and this is a
paper published in 2020 one with george
stack as a first author
where we saw distinct flowering times
within and across different cbd
cultivars so the most obvious difference
here is this autoflower phenotype so
autoflowers um are the term that's used
in the cannabis community to refer to
day-length neutral plants uh they have
only a few weeks from seed to flower so
uh they're not so great when you're
planting them out at six feet spacing
but you can imagine some production
systems where you have them really close
and you can do several cycles a year uh
it's commonly believed to be a recessive
gene but there's actually been very
little published research about this
so we wanted to map this gene and
develop molecular markers for this
autoflower trade so to do this i took
two populations one was in fact one of
those cbg populations that i was talking
about earlier that was segregating one
quarter and i also made my own f2
population from a cross between an auto
flowering plant and a full season plant
and in both i saw one quarter of the
plants flowering under long days in a
greenhouse
so then i used a technique called bulk
segregan analysis
so basically what i did was i pulled the
dna from the autoflowering plants and i
pulled dna from the non-autoflowering
plants and then i used a technique
called pi bsaseq to figure out where
those two groups were different and what
i found was that there was one nice
strong statistically significant peak on
chromosome one so the autoflower trait
is located on chromosome one and within
this peak there were a few different
candidate genes and i was able to
develop molecular markers which could
distinguish all of our different auto
flowering cultivars as well as our
different segregating populations
so to further look at the effect of this
autoflower in the heterozygous case i
grew at a population last year in the
field and genotyped it with these
molecular markers that i developed so
what i found was that
it was not in fact fully recessive i
found that the heterozygous case was a
little bit earlier than the full season
here i have it demonstrated as about
being two weeks earlier and the plants
were also shorter
and had less biomass and
some statistical modeling suggests that
it is simply because these plants are
earlier
that they don't grow as tall and they
don't grow as big
so if we look back at this original
flowering time data we see that this one
locus model with this autoflower one
actually explains most of this variation
here we have our autoflowers we have our
heterozygotes and we have our full
seasons
when we look at these two cultures here
umpqua and deschutes we can see
nice segregation of one to one early to
late which again i'd hate as a producer
but as a geneticist um what's more
they're marketed as f1 so this is very
likely just a simple back cross and to
give you an idea of what that looks like
in the field both of these were from the
same seed lot and you can see this plant
here is nearly ready to harvest and this
one
hasn't started flowering at all so i
used a very similar approach to map the
difference between these two by bulking
the early and the late plants and found
that there was a nice peak on chromosome
one again but it was distinct from this
autoflower one locus being a little
further in and i've named this locus
early one
uh looking at the sequencing data that
early group was heterozygous and i was
able to develop high throughput
molecular markers which could
distinguish the groups and i'm currently
in the process of uh testing
uh for epistasis between early one and
autoflower one so if we look back at
this data here we have a two locus model
which is explaining the variation we see
we have our autoflowers our autoflower
heterozygotes with early one
heterozygote and uh lacking that and we
have our full season so there's still a
fair bit of work to do here especially
to see the effects of this early one
locus and uh hopefully we'll be able to
have that in the field this year uh
we're also very curious about this one
cultivar called late sioux it was very
very very late flowering and we think
that it might have some potential for
growth in more southern
latitudes such as florida or even
tropical locations such as thailand
one other thing that i had been working
on concerning flowering time was to look
at what cultivars would flower under 24
hour light so you could consider these
to be true day neutral and that they
will flower even when there's no night
at all so i planted out a wide variety
of populations that were distinct
taxonomically i found that the
heterozygotes of autoflowers did not
flower which was what we expected i saw
that neither the early nor the late was
flowered
but one thing that did flower that was a
little surprising was some grain
varieties from canada
and when i tested them with my marker
they tested negative uh so it's possible
that my it's the same gene but my marker
doesn't work on these populations but
it's also possible that there is some
other
gene some other something going on which
is causing these plants to be able to
flower under 24-hour light and we've
done some initial complementation
assays to see which hypothesis is
correct and right now we're leaning
towards the fact that there are maybe
several different genes conferring
photoperiod and sensitivity in him
so before i get on to my last
major segment i wanted to go over some
highlights for flowering time so i
identified two distinct flowering time
loci on chromosome one and i developed
high throughput molecular markers for
these loci i found that autoflower one
heterozygotes were earlier and smaller
than the full season plants and i've
posited that there may be several
different day neutrality photoperiod and
sensitivity genes present
um but there's still a lot of work to be
done to identify and map these genes
so the last thing that i want to talk
about is sex determination in cannabis
so as i mentioned earlier cannabis is
mostly dioecious so there are separate
male and female plants and uh that's
largely determined by um
an xxy system so female plants have two
x chromosomes male plants have an x and
a y chromosome and uh one of the things
that i've done is develop a molecular
marker that can distinguish between the
x and y chromosome so we can see here we
get two nice groups these are x y these
are x x
and uh this is all that we see under
normal populations we don't see any yys
uh so despite having a a well-defined
y chromosome uh sex determination in
cannabis is pretty labile uh
there are a fair number of plants that
have two x chromosomes but will produce
male flowers we call these meniscus and
they've found a lot of uh uses in um
in a grain and fiber production um
we also know that
certain chemicals when sprayed on hemp
will change the sex of that plant for
instance if you spray silver thiosulfate
on an xx female plant it'll produce male
flowers and if you spray ethaphon on an
xy male plant it'll produce female
flowers and those female flowers can
produce seed so this sts treatment of uh
on on
x females to produce male flowers is
widely used in the high cannabinoid
industry because
the pollen resulting from that xx plant
is going to be entirely
x so there's no y chromosome floating
around so at least most of your
plants are going to be female
but this epiphone treatment for this xy
male to female is less done um
and a large part of that is because
it's not a huge market for um
for a population that might be majority
male 1
uh one thing that we were very curious
about though was
if we could create a super male plant so
so in theory uh
if we take our x y plant which is
normally male and we spread ethethon on
it so it gets converted into a female it
will produce seed
uh if you cross those you would expect
to see 25 xx female 50 xy male and
potentially 25 yy supermale uh which is
a plant which produces only male
offspring so if you had a yy plant
crossed it with an x plant you would get
100
xy plants and this could potentially be
valuable in a fiber cultivar in that
male plants tend to flower sooner and
produce higher quality fiber but their
existence was
still a mystery
so we tried this out
and we found that there were no why why
super males observed either in
germinated plants or simply in the seeds
that we were able to obtain from these x
y plants
what's very interesting though is that
instead of the two to one segregation
that we might expect if it was simply
the case that yys weren't viable we saw
a one-to-one segregation from male to
female in the offspring so we're still
scratching our heads about this a little
bit but we think but what we think might
be going on is that there might be some
gametophytic selection maybe something
in the case of during egg or alveolar
development there might be some
expression from the x chromosome which
is required
um so ultimately what i would really
like to do is pollinate an x y female
with an x x male
but we haven't done that just yet but
that would provide evidence one way or
the other about whether the y chromosome
at the egg stage results in a viable um
plant
so overall to briefly summarize
everything that i've been talking about
so far concerning cannabinoid synthases
we've found that it's the cannabinoid
chemotype not the environment that
causes thc to spike we've seen that
chemotype 3 plants produce about 0.3 thc
at around 7
cbd and we have good reason to believe
that that's due to product promiscuity
of the cbda synthase enzyme we found
multiple kinds of cbg dominance and we
used molecular markers based on these
chemotypes to uh breed high yielding
brain and fiber cultivars concerning
flowering time i mapped two distinct
loci to chromosome one and i'm calling
them autoflower one and early one and
i've posited there are likely additional
photoperiod and sensitivity genes in uh
cannabis germplasm
in sex determination i've developed a
molecular marker for the y chromosome
and found that yy super males are
unlikely to be viable and this is
potentially a result of gametophytic
selection
so before i answer questions i'd like to
make some acknowledgments especially to
other people in larry smart's lab
notably uh george stack and craig
carlson i also like to make a special
shout out to mike quaid who did a lot of
the screening work that i was talking
about earlier i was like to thank louise
for helping set up the snacks in the
back like to thank jamie crawford from
the murr lab formerly of the vayanz lab
who has been a very valuable contact in
ithaca running the yield trials i'd like
to thank chris smart and ali kala for
their help with mythology joss robe for
all of the thousands of hplc samples
that we've gone through and my committee
members for their support
so this work was funded through three
sources including pixis international
and new york state ag and markets as
well as a new ffar hemp research
consortium
and uh before i go to questions i'd like
to make one last uh thank you to all the
companies and individuals who generously
provided the seeds which made this work
possible
so i'll happily take any questions
[Applause]
uh i have a lot of questions about the
yield
[Laughter]
being a corn guy who likes to defend
corn yield and c4 grasses um
so so
how much when you're measuring yield on
that is that dry
grain and what percent moisture are you
at on that
yeah so we
so what
right so how do we measure grain yield
and this is really jamie crawford's
wheelhouse but we do dry them to a
standard percentage and i think the
percentage is about six percent moisture
eight percent moisture
yeah
and i guess
you know
in order to if you were to support four
ton per hectare
uh protein uh coming off you know and
you have a very high level of protein
right
that's gonna
uh i have a slide prepared
so this new cultivar here a couple of
things differentiated from other
cultivars uh it has very large seeds it
has about a 24 000 seed weight as
opposed to the 13 that we normally see
it has a very high oil concentration but
very low protein concentration
and uh we've actually been doing some
work with the food science lab and found
that this protein that's being isolated
from this plant
while there's less of it on a per
seed basis it appears to be more
functional so we've been looking at the
different types of proteins that the
plant expresses there are three main
types adestins by chileans and albumins
and this cultivar that we've developed
here has a very high albumin to a
destined ratio and that leads it to
having superior solubility and
functional properties
but my issue is at four times per
hectare of high protein without being a
nitrogen fixing legume
this is going to require a heck of a lot
of fertilizer is that correct does it
take a lot of fertilizer yes
so so essentially that
may become actually an environmental
mess
i have another slide
so uh right now
this has been criminally understudied
but we think that hemp has a lot of
potential as a um
as a as a
alternate crop
in regenerative agriculture so there
hasn't been much study on this um one
interesting study out of europe found
that compared to wheat on wheat wheat on
hemp increased wheat yield by 47 which
is quite remarkable we've heard
anecdotal increases of 25
in onion or hemp or onion on hemp
this picture here we have
it wasn't a controlled experiment by any
means and it was much more dramatic in
person but we seeded some sorghum sudan
grass over
our hemp fields and just sort of looking
at this
we can see that where the hemp was
growing the sorghum syrangrass had
nearly twice the growth rate so we think
that there's a lot of potential for hemp
to be used in a system like this
uh it's also flowers quite late in the
season which might be good for
a late season bee food as for
environmentally whether it's um
all that beneficial if we need to apply
that
nitrogen to get these high protein seeds
that's an interesting concept and i'd
like to
talk with you later on that if you're uh
free yeah i mean i i'm concerned the
amount of nitrate release nitrous oxide
released to sustain that on a non-legume
would be massive
okay because that's it's impressive
level of protein
but that's a lot of nitrogen
yeah so
so it's a lot of nitrogen for sure um
so we don't know why we're getting
better yields after this it could be
something like biological
electrification inhibition which is
leading to more of that nitrogen being
retained but we don't know
so do you think the seven percent cv is
the limit or do you think there's a way
you can
further improve that while still saying
well to 0.3 so
is 7 cbd the limit or is there something
we can do around it so
it feels a little dirty doing this but
what you can do
legally is you can get your plant tested
30 days before you harvest so you get it
tested at seven percent wait 30 days and
harvest it and it's above 0.3 but it
doesn't matter because it's not the
legally binding
number there
we've also seen a little bit of
genotypic variation some are sort of low
20s for that ratio some were high 20s i
don't think we've seen anything that's
reliably over 30 to 1.
um
but besides testing and growing those
cultivars
you know we've tested a lot of different
things that might require some uh
biotechnological innovation um
yeah
question yeah just following up on that
what what is the what is uh the
what's the turn to use for this where
you know it converts to thc
product promiscuity
what what what is that like on a protein
level is that when like
the protein changes and like
three percent of the time just produces
something else yeah so the question
would be um
how does product promiscuity happen
and
i wish i knew i had a lot of plans to go
in the lab and figure that out myself
but i was unfortunately uh not allowed
in the lab for a good portion of the
past four years uh so
what probably happens is that you get um
you know it's an abstraction of a
hydrogen or something and then
uh it gets probabilistic about whether
it's going to conform one way or the
other the actual
um the molecule the cvga is probably
it's probably probabilistic whether it
goes one way or the other it's probably
what's going on but more research is
going to be required to really figure
that out
and going back to the other question
if we could engineer that protein such
that it didn't that would be a very
valuable thing i think
question in the back
um i have a question concerning the
chemotype 2 and 3 because it seems like
you still see um like a very wide range
of cbd accumulations um almost like the
quantitative the increase do you know
what like the genetic regulation for
that is is there is it just due to the
um
inactivations on the b locus or do you
think there might be mutations in the
promoter regions or like do you know
what on the genetic basis leads to this
increase
i'm sorry i'm not sure i understand the
question
you do see um like um almost
quantitative increase
in the cbd for the chemotype 2 and 3.
total cannabinoid accumulation is a
quantitative trait so what's the genetic
basis for the
uh yeah so
looking at this here
um
yeah cannabinoid synthesis it's a
complex trait about
how much cannabinoids will be
synthesized this chemotype system
doesn't tell you anything about that it
just tells you what group you're going
to be in
does that answer your question um
do you know what
leads to this
like the variation that you see within
each chemotype
um i mean there's going to be a lot of
different so what leads to variation
within chemotype so um
so like within this group here um the
variation whether a plant's going to be
four percent or 12 percent is going to
be dependent on a lot of factors uh like
there's going to be you know 10 20 100
genes which are all going to contribute
a little bit to how much total
cannabinoids the plant is going to
produce uh when you look at this
chemotype two plants it gets a little
more interesting because we see a lot
more spread across here it's not that 26
to 1 ratio that we see all the time in
these other plants and there's a couple
of things which we think are involved
there um one of the cases is because
this is heterozygous um
you can sort of see some variation
that's hidden in the homozygous case so
uh we don't have a lot of data on this
and because all of these plants test way
above 0.3 thc we can't do any of that
research here
but some thca synthases are more active
than others
so when you're in heterozygous case you
might be you know here instead of here
uh but when you're in the homozygous
case you don't see it
not sure how we figured that out since
we can't work on those points
can you talk about how you did your
complementation test can i talk about
the complementation test uh yeah so
i do have a slide for that at the end as
well and unfortunately it doesn't really
give a nice clean story um
so i have my canadian grain variety here
which is picollo and i found that it
flowered under 24 hour light i have my
autoflower one plant here which flowered
under 24 hour light and i have my f1
plant here which was a cross between
this grain variety and this
autoflowering variety
so if there were two different recessive
genes involved you would see
complementation between the two
so we would see that full pathway that
leads to photoperiod sensitive
flowering occur
but what we see here is that our grain
flowers around seven weeks our
autoflowers flower out four weeks and
the f1s flower at around seven weeks
so there might be some
dominant thing coming from that grain
variety or there might be some
interaction between whatever is going on
for photo purity and sensitivity from
the grain variety and the autoflower one
um one other interesting note is that we
have distinct flowering times for male
flowering from piccolo which is the
grain variety and this f1 with this f1
being quite a bit later in terms of male
flowering so in all i don't have a clean
story but we're doing more work right
now to really figure out what's going on
in terms of photoperiod and sensitive
flowering
support the
cbd a and thca are both converted to cbd
and thc via heat as you said does the
does heat potentially or
can you have a potential effect right
through the environment through this
heat conversion or does potentially heat
have an effect on the promiscuity of the
enzyme so what's the effect of heat
given that it appears it decarboxylates
all of these different chemicals so
that's a very interesting question
whether promis product promiscuity
changes in heat i would just guess given
my biochemistry background that it might
you know maybe there's more emotion
maybe that active site gets opened up a
little bit so it changes
but i don't have any hard and fast
evidence right there and we haven't done
very many heat trials um
partly because they're they're very
difficult to to run you can't really run
them outside and our our greenhouse
you know even that's a very difficult
trial to run um
so the decarboxylation definitely occurs
um
so all of the numbers that i've been
presenting have been total potential
cannabinoids so that would be the amount
of cbd if i converted all that cbda to
cbd
we've just found that's a much more
consistent number than looking either at
the acid or at the neutral form
so heat does have effects on cannabinoid
profiles
but those are some hard studies to run
that we haven't done any work on
one question here and then maybe we can
look at zoom yep um
i so i think when uh i'm started coming
around
i
talked to a lot of farmers that said
that like that the hemp fibers really
obscured like when they combined and so
some people know like don't touch it has
there been like mechanical advancements
to combat that or maybe genetics select
or selections
yeah so has has there been
uh mechanical or genetic selection for
plants that are easier to combine and
absolutely and that's that's one of the
big things against the 5 000 pounds per
acre is that the rest of them we can
combine because these plants have been
bred to be short to have
a comparatively weaker stem uh this is
more of a dual purpose cultivar it has a
strong stem so you're going to require
some heavy machinery to harvest it but
you could potentially get some very high
yields and that being said
there have been advances in machinery as
well notably there's a big hemp flax
combine
which can harvest the full length of the
stem and all of the grain and it can um
depending on how you use it you can also
get a cannabinoid rich floral section
after all that so advances in both yes
but to maximize yield
um
there's going to be some give somewhere
spread those
rumors but all you got to do is cover up
the shafts with pvc pipes
the canadians have been doing it for 15
or 20 years
uh
any questions on zoom
okay last chance
so you have two alleles one that has an
active thc and one that has an active cv
and there's there's no alleles that
recombine those so we have the b
that makes sense so we have the b d oil
and then the bt allele and they're not
the same genes so do we ever see
recombination and that gets into the
nitty gritty molecular genetics stuff
which is messy so
very largely we don't see recombination
between those two genes when we look at
the gene sequences it's just kind of a
mess there's a ton of gene duplications
of rearrangements of inversions
pseudogenes everywhere cassettes
retrotransposons
like every word that you can think of
that makes a thing difficult you have
there so
what we do is we treat it as two
distinct loci that don't recombine and
we're right most of the time
uh
yeah there have been people who are
actively studying to see how much
recombination really occurs and really
defining the limits of that locus
but by and large we see that this
um behaves as essentially one locus
we have not seen it yet
still looking
okay
so we learned a lot from jacob today
uh we thank him for that we also learned
there is hope
for a former serial genomicist
so
keep that in mind
uh i forgot to mention that uh jacob
will be staying on as a postdoc in my
lab
uh running my lab while i go on
sabbatical so
uh he will be around for a while
hopefully
quite a while
and again has a lot more work to finish
up on but
now for now please join me in thanking
jacob and congratulating him
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu